here with Moore the author of the new
book start Stay or Leave the art of
decision making Trey Gowdy also Fox News
contributor Jason Chaffetz Jason will
start with you well if they if they
didn't like this practice why why did
they Institute it in the last Congress
and and where are all the the where was
the condemnation from swalwell and
Schiff and others
yeah look uh Nancy Pelosi started this
but uh that was speaker McCarthy at his
best he's talking from his heart he's
putting the interest of the nation above
those two individuals look Adam Schiff
and Eric swalwell they would not pass a
security clearance to be the crossing
guard your local school let alone be one
of the most important intelligence
oversight people in the country there
are hundreds of Democrats that are more
qualified to serve on that committee and
Sean there used to be a time where you
had term limits first of all there
should be term limits for all of
Congress but term limits on how long you
serve in that committee so that you
don't reveal this intelligence and you
don't get compromised like Eric swalwell
is obviously as was briefed by the FBI
you know and and you know treya look at
the issue of Jim Jordan and Jim Banks
taking off the Jan 6 committee
um at that point the committee was
stacked they put on the two Republicans
that voted to impeach Donald Trump the
two people that hated Donald Trump uh I
don't blame Kevin McCarthy for saying
this this is a predetermined outcome
they didn't look into what the uh the
Sergeant at Arms had to say or the
Capitol Police Chief had to say or why
in writing the mayor of D.C Muriel
Bowser said no to guard troops uh at any
time why didn't they look into those
issues to prevent any incident in the
future from ever happening
yeah Sean that is the best analogy it is
not ilhan Omar it is what Nancy Pelosi
did to Jimmy Jordan and Jim Banks that
was a select committee the intelligence
committee which I served on is a select
committee you either get selected or you
don't get selected so look swalwell was
a bit player he's honestly not worth
talking about he was a bit player on
that committee I want to talk about
shift for a decade Adam Schiff has kept
you from information that you should
have had like the dossier the fact that
it was used in a fisa filing uh who paid
for the dossier he went to court Sean to
keep you from finding out things that
were true and then on the other hand
Remember The Whistleblower that he met
with but said he did not the allegations
of of collusion the reason the media is
upset is because now the New York Times
in the Washington Post and political
were not on the intelligence committee
because Adam Schiff was the most serial
leaker that I served with Jason they
have another opinion but but he was a
Serial leaker which means those news
entities now are not getting the
information that they never should have
gotten in the first place you know I I
would argue Jason that the FBI now that
this investigation in judiciary by Jim
Jordan was on last night is more
relevant than ever because of what Trey
was just talking about and that is as it
relates to the fisa application and the
dirty dossier that Hillary paid for
being used uh then we have 2020 uh you
have a young FBI agent who wrote a
thesis about how Trump and Russia
colluded in 2016 setting up FBI agents
to meet with big tech companies once a
week and tell them and warning them oh
you're going to be fed misinformation it
may even be about Hunter because they
had the hunter Biden laptop since
December 2019. do we need the FBI to be
disbanded and do we need to start again
you need to Lop off the head of that
organization if you don't get rid of the
Senior Management and the people that
are running counterintelligence in some
of these uh you know washington-based
issues then you're going to continue to
have problems director Ray was put in
place to be an Agent of Change he has
not been I think the Twitter files will
reveal I think that so-called Church
commission that Jim Jordan is going to
head up with some very serious members
of Congress who actually want to dive
into the politicalization of the FBI
that has to happen so that Justice is
believed by both Republicans and
Democrats they aren't just looking after
one or the other get rid of the
politicalization do what they need to do
in our most trusted organization it has
a serious problem and it needs fixing
Trey Gowdy same question last word
well speaking of a laptop Sean you just
proved the point what did Adam Schiff
said he said it was Russian
disinformation even though John Lee
Radcliffe the dni said it was not and
everybody knew it was not but Schiff
said it anyway because it was
politically expedient to say
congratulations to that reporter she got
Kevin McCarthy more upset than I've ever
seen him the whole time I've known him
good move Kevin good choice all right
Trey Gowdy thank you Jason thank you